your Excellencies miss guy
professor burrows miss ladies and
gentlemen I am honored to be here today
as a messenger for my Commissioner who
will be responsible in the next five
years for what we all in this room care
very much about advancing Europe as a
digital economy and society I am
particularly pleased to address you here
in Warsaw Poland my home country so full
of digital energy enthusiasm and
knowledge and I'm very happy to be
bringing you some good news
Digital is at the heart of action of the
new Commission it has been announced and
the political guidelines of President
Juncker it is it has become our mission
the mission of my Commissioner following
his mandate letter and it has concrete
eyes a bit more in more detail and the
Commission's work program for this year
where digital figures very prominently
our vision to make Europe a truly
digital economy and society is based on
two pillars deployments of digital
networks helped by the recently released
investment plan for Europe and strategy
for the completion of the digital single
market we are confident that time is
ripe for deployment of digital networks
on a grand scale yet at a time of crisis
we must be smart if we fund only with
grants high-speed broadband
infrastructure
there will be funding gap structural
funds as much as we can insist with
member states under use for high-speed
broadband will not be enough in order to
cover all of Europe with nga we estimate
that 200 billion euro would be needed
and this money has to come from the
private sector what we need is the
leverage effect of longer-term investors
like insurance companies or pension
funds these would empower international
financial institutions and commercial
banks to take more risks this was our
goal when we proposed the connecting
Europe facility and we are really
disappointed when it received a much
smaller financial envelope than what was
originally requested but now with the
new Commission has come the time to
review our ambitions upwards the new
Commission fully recognized fully
recognizes that boosting European
infrastructures including notably
broadband is key for digital growth our
economy in society so badly need as you
know President Juncker
had tasked vice-president catenin
at the very beginning of his mandate to
present proposal for 315 billion euro
package of private and public investment
within the next three years
this took form of the recently released
investment plan for Europe with this
strong focus on
structures including broadband we should
get a fair share of the package within a
framework of the pipeline building
exercise we have got from the member
states almost 500 proposals for ICT in
broad on projects covering a total
investment sum of more than 150 billion
euro over 2015 17 the main pillar of the
investment plan will be new European
funds for strategic investments to be
set up within the European Investment
Bank member states directly or fraud or
national promotional banks will have the
opportunity to contribute to the fund by
paying in capital a clear focus of the
investment package will be the support
to investment in ultra-fast networks as
you know our current targets for 2020
that you all so passionately criticize
are to have all EU citizens connected to
30 megabits per second and all of them
connected 200 megabits per second what
we are worried about is actually that
the second objective is at serious risk
of not being achieved within the time
frame at the same time there is a clear
demand for in-house high quality
personalized entertainment Ultra HD also
gaming as we have seen in the beginning
of this event a multi-screen and multi
device vision teleworking that was also
mentioned here and innovative SMEs
require guaranteed upload speeds we have
not yet assess the need for fixing
in our higher target like one gigabit
per second but we clearly see the
emergence of such innate in this context
we realize that investment in fiber our
future proof drive innovation and
development of new services this is why
we will be looking at supporting fiber
networks ultra-fast networks
rollout as a key priority in the new
investment package while there is a lot
of potential under the new plan for
broadband funding we should keep in mind
that projects will be funded on the
first-come first-serve basis so
attractiveness of digital project is of
key importance we also want to support
companies that can deliver business and
services on such enhanced networks so
the plan will also leverage EU funds to
deliver 75 billion euro investment for
innovative SMEs and mid-caps
we have started to prepare the ground
for such funding already earlier for
instance last summer we have launched
the connected communities initiative to
gather information about high-speed
broadband project considered plant by
promoters at the regional or local level
the proper funding for digital
infrastructure in Europe has to be
complemented by a regulatory environment
that makes investment easier and foster
a common market for digital services
Europe clearly markets and scale as much
as capital are needed by European
digital industry if it wants to succeed
the EU market of 510 million citizens
represents a massive opportunity for
digital entrepreneurs of Europe's of
Europe but there are challenges for
anyone who wants to capitalize on such
an opportunity consider for a moment the
digital the soy border border less
nature of digital does it still make
sense for every new country to have its
own rules for telecommunications
copyrights data protection online
purchases and digital products all
spectrum management our response to this
is that what we need instead is a
connected digital single market with
more common rules such markets would
allow EU companies scale to compete
globally again clearly big market of 510
million consumers customers is a much
bigger incentive to invest than smaller
national markets it would also enable
traditional firms and industries to
modernize their businesses it would
benefit consumers through greater
customization and variety of services
and it would stimulate demand for
high-speed broadband
president Juncker has made the digital
single market one of the top three
priorities for his mandate and you are
going to see things moving fast in this
area strategy for the European digital
single
it will be presented very soon in spring
possibly in May the digital single
market needs an investment friendly
regulatory environment the previous
Commission has taken first steps for
improving investment conditions in the
common market in the internal market
including more pricing flexibility for
ng access in the recommendation on
costing and non-discrimination the
directive on broadband cost reduction
that has the potential of reducing the
cost of broadband investment by up to
30% we have also the EU guidelines for
application of stated rules to the
broadband sector that have been revised
last year and are instrumental in
facilitating developed deployment of
broadband however more has to be done
the proposal for the telecoms single
market which remains a priority for the
new Commission aims at addressing some
key bottlenecks that result in a
fragmentation of the European telecoms
markets it has the focus on net
neutrality roaming and spectrum and on
the latter as you know the Commission
has been very ambitious to ensure
greater consistency and its original
proposal and we will keep that ambition
in the future as per the mandate letter
we have received the telecom single
market regulation is however only an
intermediate step towards the words
achieving it truly connected continent
in Europe in the upcoming review of the
regulatory framework that will be part
of our digital single market strategy we
will have to take into account
in the gradual transition from copper to
the NGA networks operators need to be
able to explore new opportunities both
in terms of technologies and business
models that deliver them and this
process we will be looking very
carefully at the issue of how to give
priority to the rollout of fiber
ultra-fast networks because again as we
have seen in the beginning of today's
conference and the digital single market
no fiber means no party we are convinced
that only by combining these two aspects
in our policy proper funding and the
right regulatory environment will be
achieve what we should be all aspiring
to making Europe best-in-class in terms
of connectivity as a durable foundation
for a thriving digital economy and
society I wish that your debates and
today and tomorrow will contribute to
achieving this ambitious goal thank you